malgré lui l'étincelle qui allume un
immense brasier une révolte sanglante
resté dans les mémoires
frantz moffatt avait t-il pris la mesure
de ce qui se passait pour toi c'est pour
toi ce qui se passait pas bon je suis
pas un banal accident de la circulation
suivi d'une bagarre qui a eu des
conséquences dramatiques
trois morts dont le souvenir a été
inscrit ici sur la savane
une histoire qui retiendra surtout un
contexte social explosif
les usines sucrières ferme au fur et à
mesure la société martiniquaise est
gangréné par les inégalités sociales et
raciales
une histoire qui retiendra aussi la
disparition des crs de la martinique et
une politique d'un départ organisé des
jeunes et plus généralement de la
population vers la métropole
le gouvernement considère que si on
laissait je ne suis le terrain ça ne
viendra dire couilles pour le parti
communiste
j'ai considéré comme la cible alors
qu'en fait ils sont pas particulièrement
actif pendant cinq ans ils n'ont pas
crié ses quatre fils n'ont pas organisé
les émeutes
le bonhomme est dans la même logique
c'est à dire que l'on l'on évacue le
problème en faisant pas anti au legends
france vous faites est resté très
discret l'homme n'est pas connu mais il
a marqué par son charisme
passionné de foot et de pétanque son ami
témoigne d'un homme d'une grande
intégrité
c'est un monsieur doigts et juste qui a
dû beaucoup de services à beaucoup de
gens mais qui avait un mais respecte
tout le monde mais ne cherchez pas vous
allez retrouver
france moffatt est mort à l'âge de 92
ans sa veillée à